ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre vous vous seriez vanté il y a
peu d'avoir réussi en quelques jours ce
que Géral daranin n'avait pas su faire
en un an mais à quel prix vous avez jeté
la majorité présidentielle et le pays
dans les bras du Front National au soir
de son élection face à Marine Le Pen
grâce aux voix de la gauche Emmanuel
Macron promettait d'être un barrage face
au Front National et ses idées il ajouté
j'ai conscience que ce vote m'oblige
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite n'a plus
besoin d'être élu vous appliquez son
programme et faites votre la préférence
nationale vous affirmez pourtant que ce
projet de loi est conforme à vos valeurs
madame la Première ministre supprimer
laame est-ce conforme à vos valeurs
privz des étrangers en situation
régulière de prestation social est-ce
conformme à vos valeurs fermez la porte
de nos universités aux étudiants
étrangers est-ce conformme à vos valeurs
écarter des étrangers des dispositif
d'hébergement d'urgence est-ce conforme
à vos valeurs soutenir un texte dont
plus de 20 mesures sont
inconstitutionnel est-ce conforme à vos
valeurs vous vantez de ne pas respecter
les décisions de la CEDH est-ce cela vos
valeurs madame la Première ministre
ressaisissez-vous vous devez mettre un
terme à cette dérive que nous
continuerons pour notre part de
combattre à chaque étape
merci la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outr Mair à vous monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur leés Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs madame
la
sénatrice ce que l'on peut constater
c'est quand même votre vision
extrêmement partiale et partiel du texte
qui a été adopté hier par le Sénat et
par l'Assemblée nationale d'abord dire
que non il n'y a pas de fermeture des
étudiants étrangers en venant en France
il y
a il y a une volonté il y a une volonté
du
législateur de pouvoir vérifier qu'
s'agit pas de personnes qui utilisent en
effet la grande générosité de la France
et le président de la République a fixé
à 100000 étudiants chaque année vous
n'avez jamais fait ça lorsque vous étiez
en responsabilité des personnes qui
pourraient venir sans faire des études
étant irrégulier il n'y a pas de l'aide
médicale d'État supprimé il n'y a pas la
fin du titre d'étranger malade supprimé
il y a en revanche tout ce que vous
n'avez pas fait quand vous étiez en
responsabilité vous avez voté hier
contre lesirrégularisation des es qui
n'ont pas de papier qui travaillent dans
nos entreprises on retiendra ça de la
nupesse dont vous faites partie il y a
aussi madame de La Gonterie de votre
part avoir voté contre un texte qui pour
la première fois interdit les mineurs
dans les centres de rétention
administratif on retiendra ça de votre
position mais c'est pas très étonnant
madame de La gterie que vous agissz
ainsi parce qu'en fait la nuupes à
l'Assemblée nationale sans doute sur
votre recommandation à mêler amler ses
voix avec le rassemblement national pour
ne pas discuter et vous n'avez que le
fruit de votre petite politique
politicienne mais nous hier nous avons
su faire voter un texte sans compter les
voies du rassemblement national par nous
avons le nous avions le sens de
l'honneur alors que vous vous n'avez que
le sens de la petite politique merci
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
pour 43 secondes je vous en
prie monsieur le ministre je connais
bien ce texte j'ai passé 14 heures en
commission mixte paritaire si vous ne
croyez pas ce que je viens de vous dire
ou si vous pensez que c'est un mensonge
écoutez les présidents d'université et
les responsables de grandes
écoles vous savez que vous savez
concernant laame que vous pouviez très
bien attendre que le Conseil censure
cette disposition la première ministre
s'est engagé à la réformer et d'ailleurs
Aurélien Rousseau est parti concernant
les mineurs en CR vous savez que la
Convention des droits de l'homme vous
interdit d'ors et déjà de les placer en
rétention donc c'est une habileté
monsieur le ministre madame la Première
ministre rappelez-vous le mot de
Churchill vous aviez à choisir entre la
guerre et le déshonneur vous avez choisi
le déshonneur et vous aurez la guerre
c'est sans doute aujourd'hui ce que vous
êtes en train de
[Applaudissements]
faire